[Musique]
le vrai défi qu'il avait celui-là
deuxième saison devait
pouvoir entrer dans ce monde en
profondeur et faire agir un énorme
liberté en partant d'une source
littérature aussi importante que dans le cas
de la quadrilogie des livres de
ferrante est toujours difficile à réussir
ont la même réponse
d'où le succès de la première saison
oui je l'appellerais incroyable elena
ferrante a également participé à cette
deuxième saison en tant que membre actif de la
groupe d'écriture dans le but disons
pour aider et apporter des solutions
ce processus délicat et complexe de
adaptation d'un grand roman en huit
scénariser à nouveau sa présence
votre participation est essentielle
car alors les personnages sont les siens
personnages et les connaît mieux que
quelqu'un d'autre
la seule solution ensemble est la raréfaction
dans les blagues créer un seul
distance pour arriver à être moins
concret et possible le caractère de
là, il subit divers changements aussi dans
cette saison change de look
cette chose me donne l'occasion d'expérimenter
pour profiter tellement tu parles je suis
là a commencé la relation entre l dans l'ile dans
cette saison est très changée en direct
deux vies complètement différentes mais
malgré cela ils arrivent à se donner de la force
dans ce monde si violent si dur
dans lequel ils vivent cette saison
souvent et volontiers on les voit
distant comme s'il y en avait un grand
incompréhension entre eux
l'inaf à ça pour la femme une amie
ne devrait jamais faire
est désormais vraiment le
leurs chemins se séparent dans un sens
définitive je dirais
[Musique]